at world's 2018 the impossible happened
by now you've probably already heard the
story we've only made three other videos
about it the defending world champions
Genji losting groups one and five the
powerhouse first seed kt rolster went
down in quarterfinals and the frico
freaks
completed the trend we'll say 300 lost
to cloud nine it's not just the first
time that Korea has a Mista final since
they got a server it's not just the
first time that Korea didn't win world
since 2013
gingy didn't even make it out of
quarterfinals they only won one game for
the greatest region in the history of
league of legends it was a disaster so
what happened
first of all let's be clear
Koreans are still a threatening of
Legends world's was not about the end of
lck as a region for example bad players
on bad teams don't do stuff like this
all those minions will be their
advantage all right all the way to Team
Liquid pump is running for his life for
this
the AG's going to take him down
potentially a plane coming in here from
you tell that engage you might be
talking about ring of frost quick Nanook
smithy and Olay Xfinity trying to get
the stun onto mod about how he is locked
up and taken down a double kill for tap
what this tournament was about was the
rest of the world catching up producing
world-class players in their own right
and maybe most importantly the fact that
much of Korea's a world's 2018
contingent had a had a read on the meta
let's start there the world 2018 meta
was defined by aggression I guess our
trait would be proactive aggression but
we couldn't really show it at first and
it took a lot of time and now I think
it's really coming out every able to
show that but also those other teams are
super aggressive too and I think that's
just like the winning thing for this
world is aggression because have you
seen all the Korean teams like they try
to play it slow they try to play around
the vision but then everyone just goes
for the fight in darkness historically
Koreans have excelled in an environment
where they can play a low risk style
where they can set up short things and
profit from perfect calculated classes
what's more Korean players are usually
the first to find out what the best way
to play is they set the meta and the
rest of the world catches up this time
though for me the first real time in
League of Legends history they had the
wrong idea there were two teams in Korea
who excelled in fast and aggressive
games kings own dragon X the kings of
the
split and faltered in the summer and
newcomers Griffin a team of challenger
players who made it all the way to a
five-game lck finals but along with
King's Own belted Genji in the regional
finals so why did they lose it's hard to
pin down exactly what happened but the
simplest answer is that Genji had a
better read on the game of the time they
played the gauntlet for all intents and
purposes three sentient team that was
most ready to face international
competition but Genji the defending
world champion vaulter it's the worst
international performance a Korean team
has ever put up and it came in part
because Genji wasn't ready to play the
game
at the speed that the world met at the
game when people say that Korea played
too slowly at world 2018 they mean that
Genji did a frico on the other hand
didn't look too bad in groups sure they
lost a few games but they still made it
out in first place and then they got
dismantled by cloud 9
but you shouldn't dismiss the freaka for
being a trash team just because they
lost to see not sure game 1 was a stomp
that that's how the world's meta went
cloud 9 got a leave and they closed it
out but game chill was back and forth
and let's not forget about game 3-1 or
an auto attack on Baron was enough to
change cloud 9 today that looks pretty
slim market guardian angels active on
Kraemer antes this provides a tremendous
amount of an advantage for the next few
fights fence carriage is still on
without here for cloud 9 they do not
want the heart oh they're going for it
Oh
this could well be it look gonna clean
up than that of course you have the
wiggle room to make a bold play like
that when you're up - oh but cloud9
didn't roll a frico in every game a
freakin we're a strong team that lost in
part because of a topple a mash-up that
everyone thought would favor heat after
Conan I've seen of Geum woman who had a
kitten Mews oh sorry c9 so lanes I'll
perform a free cos and that's a pretty
crazy statement on a time the objective
doesn't go down that burns those dance
but he wants a Chuck takes it's rare
than an a-team can individually
outperform a Korean team like that
now did a frico play a little too slowly
probably but it's not like a meta that
favored carry so leaners did in favor
key cloud9 just had a better idea of how
to play the world's meta and the solo
laner who could make that work for them
which brings us to kt rolster kt were
korea's big hope in groups they look to
be the only korean team that was living
up to the hype there is a ray of
sunshine in all of this there is one ray
and that of course is kt rolster they
are the super team that came in as the
number one seed from the l ck and of the
three teams the Korea sent to world kt
plead the fastest they were built as a
super team packed with carry potential
with smeb in the top lane and a young
but powerful you Cal holding down mid kt
snow balled and blew open games in korea
but to understand how IG upset them you
really have to look at the gaps in
Katie's play and where IG really Shawn
up until the finals IG looked strongest
in their dominant so lowlands
in the middle of my back down at you and
wind because lighting is place for you
gals gonna be dropping neck and kg are
destroyed in this fight Shango that I
meet the turret nope nope one more shot
that's gonna be taken down a double kill
/ - rookie head IG by the knee right the
shy commanded top so thoroughly that he
made some em look far from the world
class carry he'd been back home they
might have died them though you could
make that happen the clock of come in
Spence not able to find himself a stun
he's gonna be birthed it down nearly
immediately in the shy grab to kill and
rookie styled on new pal a player whose
champion pool did favor more control
centered pics rather than the first
heavy champions who are favorite at
Worlds I'll take it very low down to
zero and first bloods of the brook Katy
were also known for their strong fault
lane something that had been more
important in Korea than it would prove
to be a world in the end 80 were
outclassed by a team that outperformed
everyone's expectations
and made it close but I just played
better overall so what does this all
mean for Korea well first of all the
region isn't do they still have many of
the best players in the world the best
infrastructure and League of Legends and
a talent pool that's always been able to
produce a world-class play rookie may
have committed himself to China but he
came up in Korea and the shy also got
his start in Korean soloqueue but for
the first time ever the players
representing Korea couldn't hack it on
the world stage
they went into a tournament behind on
the meta and lost even skirmishes
against highly mechanical players from
other regions let's not beat around the
bush here this has never happened before
not like this and it's really [ __ ]
crazy but a contingent of some of the
most gifted players the game has ever
seen are going back to Korea with their
heads hung low with a bitter taste of
coming up short fresh in their minds
that is also never happened before and
you can bet they're gonna be back Korea
is going into 2019 hungry with something
to prove with a crown to reclaim and
it's gonna be one hell of a show
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]